on a essayé le premier écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement de 540 Hertz le
truc est complètement fou pour le gamer
pourquoi parce qu'en fait là on fait la
démo dans la meeting room de Asus au CES
on a l'impression qu'en fait le perso
qui se déplace c'est un stickers il est
net il est ultra net on a tellement
d'images 540 images par seconde versus
de l'autre côté 144 images par seconde
ce qui est déjà énorme 144 Hertz mais là
en 544 ça apporte une fluidité donc pour
tous les gamers qui vont vouloir se
faire plaisir ce moniteur là franchement
il déchire d'ailleurs je sais pas ça
pourrait vous intéresser dites-le-moi
dans les commentaires